hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today it is black clover
o'clock as we tackle what i believe is
our first
megarock of the series being the
reincarnation arc except i have to say
right here and now that i won't be doing
it all in one go i got to a certain
point reading this arc where i just had
to stop because i felt like it had
already been like overloading me with
monumentally important stuff that i
probably wouldn't be able to go into
enough depth with if i did the whole
thing in one go so i got to around
chapter 157 i think it was which is
after astor and zora escape from the
other floaty fortress and regroup with
the remaining royal knights it felt like
a nice natural break point and we'll
handle the rest of it next week because
i think we have more than enough on our
plate here and in order to consume it
may i suggest using this subscribe
button or some sort of utensil in order
to make sure that you receive regular
black clover content
uploaded straight into your youtube feed
also do like the video to let me know if
you want more black clover because i
suspect you do but it's always good to
be safe now the opening premise of the
reincarnation arc is actually
kind of ridiculous basically we have
formed our super hit squad of royal
knights and they are ordered to attack
the highly conspicuous base
of the eye of the midnight sun and their
plan basically consists of
burst in and fight in any way you'd like
so i can't help but feel like things
weren't quite as well thought out as
they perhaps could have been for such an
important mission despite that things go
surprisingly well
until they don't and the most
revolutionary and world-changing event
to have happened in the series thus far
occurs
presenting an extermination threat to
the entire human race one in which we
sadly cannot rely on the power of the
wizard king to save us because of well
very tragic reasons and i think that's
as good a place as any to begin
one of the big reasons why i had to stop
is because i realized i was getting
further and further away from easily the
most shocking event in black clover thus
far which was when our wizard king was
overcome and killed by leaked or william
all right or not licked a dude
pretending to be licked while sharing
the body of william
if i understand that correctly which i
may not that whole thing well
that's a whole different issue whatever
the case the killing of julius is what i
would describe
as a ballsy narrative maneuver because
it's a very simple action that
completely reshapes our established
world it removes the stability of
knowing that someone will always be
there to protect us and it leaves all of
our characters more exposed than ever
before that's what i really liked about
it the idea that for the first time we
really are on our own
and in order to stop this horde of super
elves we're just going to have to band
together and you know
figure it out which has well and truly
started happening particularly with
nozzle and his uh his sort of
recognition of astor i did really like
that and i think that julius's death was
done quite well in general we got to see
his
cool grimoire and in the end his
ultimate downfall was his sense of duty
and there was even this tearful last set
of orders issued to
me it was really sudden but i also don't
know what maurice could have asked for
from this moment really however
now the problem previously i described
this as a ballsy narrative maneuver and
that's because it heavily impacts the
status quo and it takes a lot of work
for an author to re-establish that
balance work which many come to realize
they
don't necessarily want to do and i can't
help but feel like that
might be what we're in for here there
was this particular line from julius
describing his magic where he
something along the lines of the true
nature of my magic is to steal time from
a target which leaves him wide open for
resurrection by using the futures he
stole from someone else or whatever i
don't want it to happen
i hate resurrections almost universally
but it's definitely on the table but
assuming that this is his end for now i
salute
you mr wizard king you did your job well
and it's time to let the next generation
inherit this rather despairful situation
so it's probably quite ironic that i
stated i hate resurrections almost
universally during a reincarnation arc
where we brought all sorts of souls back
from
the dead but i really did love that
aspect of it and this really is one of
those points in time where tartan's
character building pays
incredible dividends due to cramming as
many characters as humanly possible into
almost every arc and being able to
fairly sufficiently explore most of them
there was this
incredible feeling of oh [ __ ] all of a
sudden this whole legion of these
characters that i love had been flipped
and for a while it left me pretty damn
mind blown because i was all like
luck klaus gauche everyone no i elect
you all
until it was revealed that these were
just elf souls put into human bodies
because up until then i was like holy
crap luck had been enough all along and
he just didn't know it as well as
everyone else which made for a whole ton
of potential wild drama like maybe the
elves having to come to terms with their
human experiences and needing to choose
a side but no it's it's just sort of
blatant body theft which is much less
interesting because it means that
characters like klaus and real and
everyone won't actually have to live
with their actions as elves and we won't
be exploring them
at all really we'll be examining the
miscellaneous elves and it's just
ah so here's the worst case scenario for
me i could see ending this arc with
everyone getting their bodies back
everyone's back to normal the status quo
was restored oh when the wizard king's
alive
if the reincarnation arc were to end
like that then i would say why bother
with
it to begin with basically i'm hoping
that tarpita follows through with the
drama he's created and that what we're
doing here has serious consequences
worthy of this epic setup and what i
will say is that i like that yuno was
able to resist the reincarnation right
off the bat i had a lot of fears of this
like artificial astar versus yuno
scenario but i'm pretty thrilled that we
don't look like we're heading in that
direction
so good on you you know your ears now
match those of your wind spirit
let's talk about mario leona vermillion
could she be the greatest character ever
in black clover
if not the greatest she's definitely a
close second behind yami obviously but
every panel featuring her was an
absolute treat she is a
true beast in all of the bestest
possible ways i mean when you have a
fire mage who can just
burn water spells and you're pretty glad
that they're on your side and as such
i'm also incredibly glad that we didn't
have to sacrifice her because it was
looking like she was going to be
visiting the wizard king in the
afterlife briefly but no this incredible
beast will live to wreck another face
also mario leona was the gateway for
introducing the concept of a mana zone
which was a fun explanation for her
insane mana use and heightened natural
instincts which then got applied to a
couple of other characters as well i
really enjoyed that expansion there are
also a couple of fantastic mirror pages
of cisco leona nozzle both invading the
hideout which made for a very hyped
beginning of the arc very cool artistic
choice there although when it comes to
art i noticed that there were a lot of
panels and sometimes flat up pages where
tarbeta
chose i think to adopt a very sketchy
aesthetic and
i'm not entirely sure why this is at
first i thought it might be the effect
of a spell or just for some dramatic
emphasis but the panels that were
affected were really inconsistent
almost arbitrary and some of them were
just very mundane shots it's almost like
tarbeta didn't have the time to finish
inking parts of these chapters and he
had to prioritize which panels to finish
but even then that should be fixed for
the volume release so it has to be
intentional right
in any case i don't quite get it and if
you have an explanation then please do
feel free to drop it in the comments
section which i just realized i can't
read out a fear of spoilers you know
what do it anyway
increase the uh the engagement of the
video and something i haven't mentioned
yet is that this part of the arc
features a very fun conflict at the
black bull's headquarters and here we go
to see our quiet trio in action being
gauche gordon and grey all of whom
start with g huh just realize that they
did pretty phenomenally though and it
was particularly nice to learn a bit
more about gordon and his creepy creepy
magic as well as his creepy creepy dolls
which actually look ever so cool they're
not creepy at all and i really
desperately want one
the big revelation to occur here though
is that we have a new or i guess
old but new to us blackpool member being
henry definitely was not quite expecting
that but it's a very solid concept a
poor bedridden magic knight using the
manner of his comrades to sustain
himself and ultimately unleash it in
mecca-related warfare against a giant
salamander it's all just a very classic
shonen plot point isn't it
and speaking of old black bulls members
zora you sneaky little prick
i spent so much of my time in the last
video explaining how good you'd be as a
member of the squad and you were already
in it why do you waste my time like this
i'm loving his continued involvement
though he represents one of the more
interesting brands of magic use and he's
always fun to be around because he can
do
pretty much everything by which i mean
he can handle comedy he's a funny dude
but he can also provide fantastic action
and then we can even go more
introspective for some very potent drama
as well add a slick and unique design on
top of that and that
is a delicious reset for a truly
captivating character keep it up buddy
alright onwards to william now and i
don't want to say i called it because
i didn't but at the same time i did i
think the words of the wizard king sum
up the situation best
so it was you but at the same time it
wasn't you and just
f right off i mean i'll reserve full
judgement until the end of the arc but
it feels a lot like tabata just
struggled to make an
actual decision and found a weird
awkward way to have both scenarios play
out and now as a result we have this
very bizarre fusion character we have
licht who is not licked in the body of
william who is william but is kind of
irrelevant because he's basically
declared himself a sweden and is staying
neutral in the conflict this whole
situation has become a little bit
convoluted within this one body and i'm
not going to lie
i'm still not actually sure who is
pretending to be licked at this stage
i'm not even sure we're supposed to know
because we do see the flashback from a
first person perspective but then you
know at the end of that chapter tamita
reveals the face of like the other true
licked and i'm just like
cool i still don't know who you are but
then again i'm sure this will become
clear in time as will the entire elf
flashback i imagine i'm getting really
intrigued by it actually especially with
the introduction of our human characters
particularly the one that seems to have
yuno's future grimoire and just what the
hell happened to cause something so
apocalyptic because it looks like not
even faked licks knows exactly what went
down that day also easily my favorite
elf and midnight sun guy thus far
returns in raya copy magic is absurd and
always great to watch in action blasi
made for a
great juicy victim for marilliona
although i think it does go to show that
prior to this whole reincarnation thing
these midnight sun guys probably would
have been scrubs compared to the full
force of the magic knights if they'd
just gotten their [ __ ] together and
attacked the base with the full
complement of captains rather than
having some sort of crazy tournament run
by a crazy king we might be sitting in a
very different place right now one with
perhaps a living wizard king back to rye
though on the verge of losing there was
a cool moment where he initiated his
self-destruct sequence and astor was
just like
i've already seen two people try to blow
themselves up so i'll just
be stopping this it was a nice meta
commentary on how these top tier
villains seem to end in black clover but
also a great moment of growth for astor
it shows that he is learning from his
past fights like a chess player
analyzing past games an extremely loud
kind of annoying chess player but still
i liked it and in the end we do have a
very solid setup here and a barrage of
events to digest which once again is why
i just had to stop and get all of this
out before continuing i also know that
i've probably dwelled on negatives a lot
in this review but something that gives
me a ton of hope is that the beginning
of black clover arcs are always my least
favorite parts they tend to feel
standard tropey and kind of
uninteresting however there is always a
point where tamata flips a switch and
turns them into something very
compelling unique and well worthy of the
setup and i have no reason to believe
that the reincarnation arc won't follow
that trend it has already flipped
several switches actually which is why
i'm very excited to see where this
madness follows but that pretty much
does it for this blind review of this
part of the reincarnation arc and what
do you guys think please do leave your
thoughts in the comments below or even
join my discord server and if you're
keen for some more black glove content
then please to go and check out some of
my other videos or even subscribe to the
channel for very
maybe regular black clover goodness
delivered straight into your youtube
feed but for now this has been the new
world review and i'll see you next time